okay great so very good
okay so uh
my plan was to discuss
preparation of tables for machine
learning and
and the organizers saw something
interesting in my uh in my abstract and
put it as a title
it's a really so really the plan is to
is to discuss preparation of table for
for machine learning and
um
well the reason I'm interested in this
is it just keeps coming up as a
bottleneck to machine learning practice
when you talk to people
and you know in many different aspects
the data preparation is absolutely
crucial to the analysis and I claim that
you know most of what we do in in by
data is is basically managing around
with vendors and uh and so the the the
question I'd like to ask and I've been
you know going around this for a few
years is can we have better pipelines
better software that reduces this need
and and during this talk I will focus on
supervised learning so it's something
that is good is something that gives a
good prediction if you want to challenge
me on you know does this carry over to
other things I'm interested in in the
challenge and to summarize I mean
basically I can say that supervised
learning is some form of weekly
parametric statistics and
many statistical operations can be
coined into a supervised learning uh
framework though there's a few caveats
but anyhow you know the
the way we work is that we have data and
then we need to
work on it to be able to give it to our
models
and
that calls for many things for data
curation for all kinds of data
transformations
and all these things are not automated
in any way with traditional Machinery
neither deep learning by the way
so
we prepare the data to feed the machine
and if we're looking at tables it's
mostly pandas or polars or SQL scrapes
or spark you name it and none of this is
automatic and by what I'm being told
most of day-to-day practice of a data
scientist is doing this and in my own
experience when I'm working on like real
life data science problems when I get to
the machine learning when I get to
import socket learn I mean the problem
is solved because I can spend You Know
Much Time on it but basically it's
diminishing returns
this by the way shows up in
various surveys are of different kinds
and looking at the challenges to to
data science and in various
organizations
so
I'll go for more simple problems to more
complex problems
I'll start by how do we fit the data
table
and I'll explain a bit where we're at
here
then you know what happens if the data
table becomes quite a messy table and
I'll I'll describe the kind of things
we've learned here and then I'll
describe science fiction but we're
working on this science fiction is how
do we learn assembling across tables and
this is ongoing work
all this is somewhat of a back and forth
between research I do as an academic and
and software development that we do in
various places
so
most of the data in a given organization
I'm not talking about the kind of data
you can get on on internet or via
sensors
is tables
and if if we want to take like a
mathematician point of view because
we're in the math department
those tables don't live in a vector
space
and being somewhat of a mathematician
myself I feel uncomfortable outside of
vector spaces but that's the way it is
so most of data is tabular
so what works for learning on tabular
data
a year ago we looked at uh we did we did
a benchmark of recent architectures that
claimed that they were good on on
tabular data and there's been a lot of
papers that have been published on
tabular deep learning
and so we tried many things out there
actually the goal was not to do a
benchmark but just to use things but we
were kind of surprised by what we saw so
we tried many things out in our
conclusion
across various data sets is that
there's been many Publications on like
fancy deep learning methods but for your
typical data set
tree based methods work better
and this by the way was published in
Europe's which is one of the places
where you publish fancy deep learning
methods so we got fairly hard review on
this
and you know maybe maybe one way of
summarizing the thing is that of course
get for a given data set if you tweak
enough with a given deep learning method
you might be able to outperform the tree
based method but the question is across
many data sets with give given a certain
budget of hyper parameter search what
you get
and I'd like to stress by the way on
this slide that things like
xgboost are extremely popular where is
XG boost on the slide yeah so it's the
Deep green it's the the Deep green line
that goes like this
but what we find is is that psychic
learns that his gradient boosting treat
or classifier regressor uh actually
performs really well if you're given a
limited budget much much better than the
NXT boost so that's also an interesting
reality check for for us I can learn
whether we still have an edge
now this a slide was for regression for
classification is approximately the same
picture
our Edge isn't as big by the way
so uh I find that many people don't
realize that scikit-learn has a modern
performant implementation uh for
gradient boosting
that's fast and works well so so here it
is
and in general if you have tabular data
you probably want to use gradient
boosting with the his gradient boosting
algorithms and psychic learning or
actually boost or others actually
catboost we haven't tried but I'm sure
it works really well
why is that the case why do trees work
so well for tabular data if you think
about tabular data what we have is that
each column is going to have a different
data distribution
so each of those marginals the column
wise data distributions are going to be
different and they're going to be often
vastly non-gocious you know think of a
names distribution of a population think
of an income distribution think of a
weight distribution all these things are
severely non-gocian and they're all
interesting by themselves and then we
have lots of categorical features
and trees work really well on this first
they make access aligned thresholds so
basically they do cuts on a single
column that's totally relevant you know
it's probably hard to define a cut on a
combination a linear combination of your
age your weight and your income
and then second
trees are non-smooth and empirically in
the paper we show that this is actually
useful this is not something I was
expected but we showed that on many data
sets the regression function is actually
non-smooth it actually has
some very strong irregularities if
you're looking at consumption of
electricity as a function of time
it just does jumps and those jumps are
somewhat reproducible across days
so from a research standpoint by the way
this is interesting because in in the
paper we showed that the natural
geometry of the data is neither smooth
nor victorial which from a deep learning
perspective is annoying
by the way I also do research on deep
learning so this is not something I find
convenient
it's just it's just there it also
doesn't mean that in some future we're
not going to come up with an
architecture that works well but
currently if I have a practical problem
I don't bother I use gradient boosting
so
missing data missing data is very
frequent in applications such as health
and social sciences
technically
it's a mixture the the real problem is
when we have a mixture of continuous
menus and every once in a while a
discrete missing value
by the way if we have categorical data
and every once in a while a missing
venue it's not a problem you just
allocate the missing value to a new
category called missing and you move on
with your life but when we we have
discrete continuous values and and we
have discrete missing this
pose this problem
there's a vast literature on missing
data in statistics
if you're interested in the theory uh on
this literature we can take it offline
so the standard practice is to do
imputation
for machine learning we need to do
imputations that work out of sample
that so we need to fill in the blanks
with likely values but working also on
the test set that we've never seen
so many of the implementations break
because it's hard to do this
and so in in cycle earning we started by
doing very simple imputation for
instance mean imputation you just
replace the missing value by the mean of
the of the feature
from a classic statistic point of view
it is disastrous because you're creating
some abnormality in the middle
which is your imputation you've
distorted the distribution you don't
want to do this it breaks
the kind of things you expect in
statistics
let's leave this on the side for now
we can do more complex imputation and we
can do what I will call conditional
imputation so you're trying to estimate
the expectancy of the missing values
given the observed one
this is the classic thing that is done
in standard statistical practice
putting multiple imputations aside
one way to do this is to use predictors
to predict one feature as a function of
another we have this in socket learn
it's known as the iterative imputer
and has disastrous computational
scalability because you basically keep
you know predicting things as function
of each other it scales really poorly
but it should be a better computation
so now if we're looking at imputation
for prediction if we want to use
standard statistical result they tell us
and I'm not going to go too much in the
details but they tell us that imputation
is legit from a statistical standpoint
only if the data is missing at random
which means that the missingness is
independent from The Unseen values
so basically you know you've known form
of like censoring
happening
spoiler
seldom happens in real life usually when
the data is missing it's missing for a
reason
but to do the proofs and statistics this
is super useful
in real life we often have informative
missingness you know you could for
instance have the value uninteresting
but the fact that it's missing
interesting these things can happen
so if you're ever going to impute
actually with the simple computers may
be less important but if you're ever
going to impute
I suggest that you use the adding
indicator function in cycle or in which
tells adds basically an extra feature
that says where we've imputed in
practice this really helps
now with a few characters including
Marina marthon we did a
fairly powerful theorem a few years ago
which tells us that
if we have what we call a universally
consistent learner so something that is
very flexible flexible enough
it will give optimal prediction for all
missing data mechanisms so we don't need
a missing at random assumption anymore
and almost all imputation function
so basically asymptotically if we have
enough data Computing well is not needed
to predict well
you can impute poorly you do a horrible
imputation and a flexible learner what
happens is that the harmful imputation
creates structure in your data the
flexible learner recognizes the
structure
this by the way is standard industry
practice it's just Academia catching
upright
but the theorem is there it's quite
powerful
statisticians don't like it
really what's happening is that we're
putting all the complexity in the in the
learner now maybe this is a bad idea so
then we looked at you know how can we do
trade-offs of complexity between the two
and the paper goes in more details but
basically in the paper what we showed is
that in general
imputing by the conditional expectations
so doing a good combination conditional
imputer was not always a good idea and
the reason is the following if you have
curvature
in your in in the function that that
links the fully observed data through
the output so basically if your output
Depends for instance as a
the square of the fully observed data
when you impute by the conditional
imputation
you're forgetting the conditional
variance
there is uncertainty on this imputation
and that uncertainty is converted to
bias by the nonlinearity so if you don't
have if your predictor your ground truth
mechanism is not a linear function
you will lead in two problems
now statisticians will tell us yes but
multiple imputation in which case I will
say yes but Ensemble methods and they're
super useful but it's a different story
now when we have trees
in a sense all this doesn't matter
because you can specialize the trees to
deal
with missing values so as you're
learning the tree learning the tree is
basically learning thresholds as you're
learning the trees you're special casing
when you see a missing value and you're
doing this in a supervised way
and this works really well because you
can adapt to like informative
missingness you can adapt to all kinds
of things
this is implemented in psychic learns
his gradient boosting classifier
and Alexander
in my lab ran some fairly intense
benchmarks on real life data set and we
learned a ton of things during this
and by the way what we learned their
backs of it some of my claims
and kind of our conclusions was
this approach missing incorporate
attribute which is also implemented in
XC boost by the way
uh works really well
it's works as well or maybe better than
a very sophisticated imputation but it's
much much more scalable and much cheaper
so missing data Maybe you know some take
home messages
if you're looking at machine learning
imputation is not about finding likely
values it's about facilitating the
learning those two things are related
but not exactly
if you really want to use a smooth
machine learning predictor for any kind
of Reason use an iterative imputer but
add the indicator
but if you're willing to go for trees
they can handle missing values natively
and so we just merged
in the random Forest
in cycle learn the handling of missing
values and it's going to be out in two
weeks
but it's already in the his gradient
boosting
okay so if we want to fit data tables
it's actually fairly simple
we just use tree base models such as the
his gradient boosting
because they're basically well suited to
the nature of tabulary data
indicator for missing then
if really you don't want to do this then
some tips
use the quantile Transformer which will
basically adapt the distribution of each
column to make it more gaussian or more
uniform
and use the iterative imputer with ADD
indicator equals true for the missing
values
but I wouldn't bother
okay sometimes the tables are a bit more
messy
you might have things like dates times
or columns that are
strings that look like categories but
not very well normalized
so in such a setting we're basically
going to have to transform this this uh
data frame into something that is more
regular ideally numbers because machine
learning works well numbers
and that's where the effort goes a lot
of effort
so you know let's let's think about it
in the in the simple way we would
naturally do it and I'll start with like
the the simple column
gender here male female should be easy
to do so we need to transform this to a
numerical Matrix and one way of doing
this is to use the pandas that get dummy
on this and penis get Demi will create
you know two columns
uh one and zeros that encode the
different values
fine what if new data comes in we do
machine learning if we do machine
learning we want to be able to predict
on new data
should we call get that means again
if we do this what if the columns appear
in the in the same will The Columns
appear in the same order
is this guaranteed I don't know panda is
well enough to be certain but I'm I
someone think this is related to the
order in which the category is appear
what if we have if for instead of
categories a new one
it's going to create a you know
data set with a different number of
columns and then cycle learner is going
to complain
so
the way we're going to do it in the
socket learn-ish way of doing it is that
we're going to have an object that's
called the one hot
encoder we're going to fit it on the
data frame and then we're going to
transform and we can transform the same
data or other data and the really
important part here is that the fit and
the transform are two different things
so we separate learning the data
transformation from applying it and
that's something really really important
and I I I I'm misconfessed I don't see
enough people doing this including in my
own lab
and the reason is it's tedious
but if we don't do this the chances of
data leakage are very high we keep
seeing this in my own lab all the time
it's much harder to put in production
you know you've built your own Pipeline
with the idea that you have the full
data but ah now you need to put it in
production you don't have the full data
and building a pipeline like this
enables you to do model evaluation or
model selection on the full pipeline
which I think is really interesting and
I'll come back to this
now that was for a very simple example
uh you know
categories simple categories
but we're going to need different data
Transformations for different columns
for instance we have the column date
hired
so we can convert this into a time in
seconds
but maybe we want more than this maybe
we want to encode to capture some
regularity maybe we want to capture the
day of the week
the month because it really helps the
the predictor
you know maybe some things happen
differently on Sunday than the other
days of the week
so for this
we have uh the date time encoder
this code doesn't run actually but I
forgot the parenthesis to instantiate
the daytime encoder so we have the date
time encoder that that can you know fit
and transform and comes with Hyper
parameters such as you know do you want
to represent the days of the week and
everything and we try to to
take good defaults for those hyper
parameters now you'll notice that this
actually is in a new package that is
called scrub
and I'm actually overselling because
scrub isn't even released it's got a big
warning on their website that says not
released
so why a new package
because
a lot of the data in tables actually
has a nature that is more of a nature of
databases it's full of discrete elements
it's full of different types and
numerical types
and we find that there is a need to
basically Bridge machine learning to
databases databases at large right I'm
not talking only about relational
databases I'm talking about
data management
and so we've decided that that we're
going to start a new adventure that's
called scrub and our goal in scrap is
really to facilitate preparating
tables for machine learning
I'll come back to this
okay so now we have our solution we have
to do data messaging but we'll do this
by deploying different Transformers to
different columns in a pipeline
experience shows that this gets very
tedious because you need to Define
really big objects that
single out columns and Transformers and
this it works it's just annoying code
and
Sometimes some columns just don't fit in
the framework
and some kinds of columns that don't fit
in the framework
is
this kind of column which is you know
this by the way is a categorical column
it's just a categorical column with
gazillion of categories
it's curated data this is officially not
messy data
so the problem that we have here is the
problem that in databases is called as
entity normalization or you're trying to
encode better the data or actually
database normalization
but the point of view we're taking is a
different one
we're taking the point of view that
those strings database people call them
surface forms those strings
capture a lot of the information that
we're interested in
and so those are real databases and what
you find is that in real databases
there's a lot of structure in the string
and so what we're going to do is that
we're going to model the strings
and one of the approaches that we took
was something that we call the Gap
encoder
it basically builds embeddings of
strings and it does this using a classic
approach in in text modeling which is to
look at the substrings that are in a
given string and we can basically build
a large comp Matrix of substrings
and then to factorize it as in topic
modeling
and so we get you know two matrices one
which describes
what I will call latent categories and
one and another one which tells me how
how much a latent category is loaded on
the on the string
and we can we can do math
but the point being that if we we do
this well we observe things like this
so what you see here is that the
loadings this is purposely taken in a
very low dimensional this is there's
only 10 categories then latent
categories
and what you can find is so we've
imposed the loadings to be somewhat
sparse and positive and so what what we
find here is that each original category
is defined by a combination of a small
number of latent categories
and then we can
do hacks
because those are hacks they're not
principled but we can do hacks and and
have feature names that are associated
to those latent categories and so what
we have here is something that's a bit
like a one hot encoder but works on
finding regularities in the streamism
to Define them latent categories
and this is nice because you still have
some form of interpretability like the
one hot encoder but it's pretty robust
to you throwing in data that's not been
normalized that comes in with typos and
things like this
it does have the
sometimes being slow we're working on
this it's basically convergence criteria
as of a online uh
mm algorithm but whatever
and so there's another version of
something quite different which is very
very fast it's stateless so basically
you can distribute it you can vectorize
a full database by by Distributing it
over the network
it's not very interpretable it's based
on Min hash Min hash is the randomized
uh
representation
which
captures
set inclusion
and you can see it here because on this
representation you can see that here I
have the the embedding
of technician Supply senior
and the thing that has senior Supply
technician is below all the other
embeddings
so there is
it works really well for trees because
this below
is something that is extremely well
captured by a tree
however it is not
feature-wise interpretable at least I
haven't found a way of doing it if you
if you have an ID talk to me
and it's not going to work well for
things like linear models or or deep
learning
okay so back to data data messaging we
have cool Transformers that we can apply
on different columns in a pipeline and
they work really well
you still need to build this thing and
if I show you the code of what we call
the column Transformer it's nasty it
scares people away
so let me introduce to you the table
vectorizer the table vectorizer is a
vectorizer that takes a data frame
and transform it to a feature Matrix
it comes with heuristics
based on the type of the column
those are completely heuristics we have
tuned them on the data we'd like more
data to tune them
but what we find empirically is that the
combination of the table vectorizer and
the his gradient boosting classifier or
regressor is a really strong maze line
very very strong of course you can beat
it but it's a very very strong midline
so with this code I claim that for many
not all many
table problems you have a strong
Baseline
if you have huge tables this is probably
going to be sub-optimal because
the table vectorizer uses a gap encoder
by default you can change this but it
uses a gap encoder by default so it's
going to be snow slow as hell
and because if you have a huge amount of
data you know few hundred thousands or
more
you might want to use deep learning
though it's going to be much more work
okay
and we're still working on making this
thing really robust we've identified
things where it's not behaving as well
as we would like so we're coming up with
new heuristics this is why scrub is not
released I do hope that in a few months
scrub will be released
and this will be incredibly useful
okay so data tables
all kind of terrible things
solved
at least
to a first approximation but not a major
problem
now what's remaining is all the rest and
that's a lot
and when we do pandas typically we don't
work on a single table we work on many
tables and we're assembling them
so really what we want to do with scrub
that was the easy part what we want to
do with scrub is to tackle the full
assembling pipeline
how much time do I have
15 minutes
okay so I'm just I'm gonna walk through
a hypothetic assembling pipeline if you
do a lot of real-life data scientists
this is going to be obvious if you're
like me an academic floating in papers
this may not be
so suppose we're interested in the real
estate market
so we're interested in it in Computing
the expected price of a property we can
do this with supervised learning and
we're going to predict the price from
the information that is available so the
age the surface area the number of rooms
the floor the location
the location is an interesting problem
because
there's actually so much information in
in the location and technically what we
would really like to do is to grab
information from external tables
what's the
size of a city
uh what What's the
typical salary in a given City or in a
given locality
and maybe the data I have when I asked
the typical salary I need to compute the
typical salary from another table maybe
I have a table that tells me you know
people
salary and where they live
so I need to compute the typical salary
what's the typical salary by the way
what's the relevant quantity is it the
mean is that the median are we
interested in the person time maybe
we're interested in all this
so if we do if we do pandas this is
going to be a group by post aggregation
so this is what we're doing right when
we're preparing tables
and maybe I actually need to do several
joints because my information I need to
do multiple hops
so this is what data preparation is
about
it's really hard I find I've done this
one of the reason is really hard is it
requires human beings to understand the
data and by the data I mean all the
tables and you know if you land in a new
organization there are 25 tables just
25.
it takes a while to understand those 25
tables
and then you also need to understand the
Learners the engineering
and
the application
data science question you're interested
in
real estate what's important for Real
Estate
and even with all this
you're being sub-optimal because they're
all kind of proxies
of
say socioeconomic status things like
this in your data that are really hard
to capture and takes a lot of expertise
to do this
for machine learning there's a technical
problem is that
that's a lot of discrete choices and so
far we don't have a tool that optimizes
so we can't automate the hard thing
and
sometimes we don't have correspondences
sometimes things break down because we
have
you know some form of normalization
problem things are not written the same
way and so it breaks down
these are the problems I'm interested to
tackle with scrub
it's going to take a while but
Serene the point with scrub is that I
believe we need statistics and learning
across tables
it's also a research agenda by the way
let me take that
a simple quote-unquote simple example of
data assembling
and the the framing is that we have a
main table and feature enrichment tables
okay but the important thing is that in
this world view we have a main table and
this main table is going to be the
repetition over which we're going to
want to predict if I do cross validation
I'll do it from the main table if I have
new data coming in those are new rows of
the main table okay
so we currently have what we call the
feature augmenter which might get
renamed to Joiner
this is subject to debate
it starts from this main table this
target table and then the joins related
table so this is this is code it's code
that you can find on an example in in
our web word page we start from the main
table
which I call DF
and here I've just put it's just
basically in the indices so names of
countries and we're going to want to
augmented and by the way technically
I've put names of countries but there is
a why that's to predict so the original
data comes with the the table comes with
a prediction Target
I don't remember what the target is by
the way on this this thing anyhow
I I need more information to predict
I don't know what we were predicting
life expectancy or something like this
anyhow so
what we're going to do then is that
we're going to go to other data sources
to enrich our data and so for instance
we're going to look at the the GDP per
country we're going to look at the
happiness rating countries have
happiness rating
and we're going to grab this say on the
oecd website or you name it and we're
going to merge them with our table this
is going to be how we augment our our
data
so with the feature augmenter here what
we have is that we have a pipeline-ish
way
of
joining information across tables
I'm not super happy with this syntax
which I find a bit
dense
maybe one day we'll do better
and here we can separate fit and
transform
what's the benefit
we can optimize this
we can use model selection grid search
tools to optimize this
by the way
you might have noticed that there are
spelling differences between those
because this happens in real life
and so the join that we're doing is
actually a fuzzy join and one thing that
that script gives is a fuzzy join we
also give like pandas like operations
but they're that are more robust to to
misalignments
and the reason is I don't want my
predictor to bail out if I have a type
or in the test set
this by the way may be incorrect joins
we have no guarantee of correctness
we're not database people we don't do
correct things
then the next thing we're working on and
we're currently working on this is what
I call a a joint aggregation so joining
on one-to-many relations
so joining summarizing the recent
purchases purchases of a customer
and here we have many different
aggregations that are possible
so this is this is work in progress we
have a pull request and an example
and hopefully this is going to happen
soon
but let me tell you about the vision
this is this is like a marketing talk
right I I don't have the code I'm going
to tell you what it's going to be
so division
is data assembly as Pipelines
because pipelines are good because they
can facilitate putting in production but
also because they can do model selection
and model validation
because they did something is important
because we need to be able to optimize
it
we're planning to cover identity the 80
use cases I don't know if we'll get 280
by the way but the point being is that
we're never going to replace something
as flexible as pandas it's not happening
you know the too many things you can do
with Benders so we're going to try to
identify the most frequent things
this might be challenging
we're going to want to have multiple
back-ends things like pullers ideally
using different back-ends efficiently
this is going to take a little while
and the benefit that we're hoping to
bring to people
is that
people who are not expert in pandas or
polars or you name it will be able to
get like their 80 use cases run
efficiently
because I find often that
the pandas code that I see written could
be written in more efficient way
so speeding up
things and ideally having people transit
to other back-ends effortless
we want to have lazy data sources this
is like starting to look in the distant
future we want to have lazy descriptions
we want one day to be able to start
directly from files on the disk directly
from a relational database and basically
do the the learning directly from this
this will decrease the memory pressure
this will enable
query plan optimization
to be more efficient
and an important thing is that we want
to be quote unquote fuzzy
our goal is to represent the message the
messiness to the learning
and
we don't have the goal of having a clean
perfect data structure in the middle
now we are going to provide
tools to clean we have at the
duplication engine not a very good one
it can be improved pull request welcome
inscribe because the goal of scrap is to
be able to work with the data people
have and not the data people would like
to have
but I think a niche that we can have is
that cleaning is extremely hard
supervised learning is easier and
combining
things that are usually sold by cleaning
with supervised learning I think is
going to get us somewhere
so what I hope is that you know
representing the data in a rich way with
machine learning can partly automate
data preparation so less manual work
and really what what I would like to
enable is to combine scleren scrub and
some form of automl
I think this is really the benefit of
doing scrub
write the pipeline optimize it for
prediction
so to summarize if you have a single
table
and it's not too dirty you should be
using his gradient boosting or XG boost
if you spend too much time encoding your
tables
you should look at the table vectorizer
and scrub well when they tackle assembly
we're working on this
so I'm super excited about Scrub by the
way it's been kind of baking in the lab
for quite a while
most of the code of scrub is actually
available under the previous version
which was called Dirty cat for dirty
categories so you can use it today
but we're not maintaining dirty cat
anymore and we are currently making some
somewhat brutal changes in the code
because we've learned things
from you know doing dirty cat
over the last few years
thank you
[Applause]
so if you have questions please raise
your hand and I will bring the mic to
you
thanks really nice talk so for your
pipeline where can I plug in
explainability if I need that for my
data you said it's hard
for people that need that do you foresee
that this can be plugged in so not just
in your learning model but also in your
scrub somehow
explainability is a difficult a question
so
in a sense we all need it because my
experience is that when we work with
data
the data doesn't always have what we
think
and we the pipelines don't always do
what we think and so if we try to do
things as black boxes things don't work
and we don't know why so just like we
need a debugger to run to run code
so I think you know so first we need to
worry about the statistical methods
what's what's behind them so the Gap
encoder I really like because it gives
you some form of explainability the Min
hash is harder
uh we're probably going to have to
integrate some form of visualization
a lot of explainability is visualization
I must also say I'm I I have a love-hate
relationship with explainability it's
rather hate hate a bit of love with it
the reason is
things are complex
whether it's a neural network or
the clinical database I'm working with
it's complex
and usually explainability is about
giving a simple story on a complex thing
and when am I lying where does it stop
so I see explainability as
something to add on as a debugging tool
but in no way some truth and here I
strongly disagree with the EU act and I
was somewhat part of some of those
things and
I think it's going in the wrong
direction you don't enforce
validity
by explainability
I do a lot of health research
yeah hi also thanks for the talk
um about the table of actuarizer is it
also working in a kind of fuzzy way so
let's say we have a for example the the
date a column of 1000 dates and there's
one poorly formatted
would it then still be recognized as a
date
there are some mechanics like this
integrated in the table vectorizer
not yet currently we're piggybacking on
pandas detection of dates and I can
I can see how it's going to backfire uh
those are things I would like to do
how fast we're going to be able to do
them it's unclear to me and we're also
you know we're also working on Psychic
learns so if we
if we one day maybe we'll be able to use
scikit-learn to detect dates things like
this you know it's a back and forth
but it's a good question thank you
hi thanks again for the nice talk and my
question goes in a bit a similar
Direction so when you have shown the
table vectorizers vectorizer you
described that there are several
heuristics that like you know you also
use to like massage the data in the
correct format and this reminded me a
bit of a project I did recently which
was a horrible hack but where we used
actually an an llm to actually write for
us the validations of some dirty data in
the real world we went with a different
approach right we use the real data to
essentially summarize it to an llm and
like you know obtain we from the llm the
some validations rules that are boring
and tedious to write and so on like we
had the horrible evil around it all but
like you know in principle I guess it's
more saying if you can just select which
sort of heuristics you want there and I
was wondering like did you have did you
do any experiment in that direction so
to use that to
you know to clean up your data in this
case because I think that that stuff
like even column names or so can give
you a lot of semantic context to know
like what to do actually with this data
to clean it up
yeah so then I'll put my researcher hat
on
uh so nlms are really interesting for
what people started calling a table
understanding which is part of data
wrangling like type detections or things
like this they work really well they
work really well for date detection and
even like Canon again
putting data in canonical format which
is really bad because you might have
dates in all kinds of different formats
so they're really really really good for
this
we have looked at using llms to directly
learn on tables they work and some
papers have been published there
but
you know with it like uh somewhat
trying to be honest in terms of
validation we couldn't really outperform
table vectorizer plus is gradient
boosting I mean we could find situations
where they outperformed but it was
wouldn't be something like I would tell
you you know there it's better
now in the future I suspect these things
are just going to get better and better
and better and so then I'll have some
kind of contradiction is that from a
philosophical standpoint I like things
to be lightweight
and easy to use Easy to install so I can
see a future how
soon is welcome I don't know but I I can
see a future well will have optional
ability to pull in language models
probably from hacking phase but we'll
see to do some things in Scrabble but
certainly
at least in their short-term future it's
not going to be you know Central because
I have the feeling that when we do these
things we're using Sledge hammers
and I don't really like that plus I I
work a lot in health in at least in
France and Hospital data does not leave
the hospital and I think it's fairly
reasonable when we see what's in the
doctor's notes it's very very private
do you plan to support a partial fit in
case of for the table vectorizer in case
of data would not fit into memory
that's a that's a really good question
so both uh the Gap encoder and the Min
hash encoders support partial fit
if we did things well
that's a big if
the table vectorize it is but I'm not
certain you want to put an issue on this
I'm serious I mean we need to we said
it's an early package we need to
identify these things
these days by the way I'm more excited
about lazy data than partial fits pick
so I've historically I've been super
excited about partial fit but people
have a hard time using it I mean this
audience is probably more expert than
the usual data scientist but people
don't use partial fit so I
Still Still Of course we need to support
it but I'm excited about being able to
pass in lazy polars or SQL queries and
then the thing in itself doing the uh
out of core Computing it'll take a while
yeah
okay I passed them back
hi a very nice talk you mentioned
already that you that you are excited
about having different backends or
support different backends I mean if you
think this very till the end then you
come up with something like a grammar
for these kind of things right so you
really
leaving python for example and then you
can think of maybe this is just SQL so
what's your take on that that's a great
question I I like that you ended up with
with SQL because I was thinking the
minute you said you said a grammar I
thought ask her okay so there's a really
there are many things in your question
first
SQL versus python so SQL from molecular
from computer science perspective is
perfect it's a declarative language that
you can analyze build a compute graph
it's coupled with the digital
representation you can then optimize the
the execution of that choreograph it's
perfect
people hate it
and there's a reason declarative
doesn't fit into people's brain which is
also why people hate the pipeline the
cycle and pipeline because it is a
decorative and because cycling was
actually built historically
to hide declarative things under
imperative
and so IGI one of the things I'd like to
see is can we hide it even more can we
do things that look like they're
declarative that that look like they're
imperative that executed that are
executed as people type but that also
build the pipeline
a bit like by torch for instance
uh
so you know
the difference with what we do is we
have Python and python is
easier to express complex things than
SQL
and this is something I really believe
in and so we we need to make it easy for
people to integrate their arbitrary
python code in what we do
and in this this grammar as you
mentioned so when I say you know we have
the the Joiner The Joint aggregator I
mean we're basically building
this grammar and in this grammar then we
need to do some of the translation
and so we're not probably going to cover
all all SQL that's the first thing the
second thing is that one of the
differences with SQL is I I don't plan
to reinvent the relational algebra
because we're here to learn
and I have like a philosophical
difficulty with the fact that the
relational algebra is basically set
theory and from a learning perspective
set theory is a disaster because it's
fully combinatorial and so as much as
possible I'd like to describe things as
continuous values because continuous
values can be can be optimized and you
know that's what's behind the Gap
encoder and these things how far are we
going to go I don't know
yeah thank you for the great talk was
really interesting I really like the
idea of scrub that helps to optimize
data preparation however I'm a bit
concerned about the fuzziness that we
introduced to our data pipelines because
the more fuzzy the system gets the more
it is error-prone what is your take on
this
I don't think this is true I think I
think I think this is the traditional
way and I've got backup slides on this
but let's not go through them I think
this is a traditional point of view I
think the traditional point of view is
that analysis are valid because they're
sharp and clean this is typically what I
hear when I talk with my my friends from
uh from the database
of you now how true is this it's going
to depend on your application but if you
have a lot of data and you have
supervision
and ideally the supervision doesn't have
biases we could we could discuss about
the biases of supervision
uh biases are present in a lot of data
but this is going to be what's going to
make your your pipeline valid
if now whenever it breaks is if you
don't have you know huge amount of data
and you want to inject human knowledge
and if you want to inject human
knowledge human knowledge is easy to
inject with
clean the idea of cleanness the idea of
correctness the idea of discrete choices
and now I think we have an interesting
space to play in and I don't have an
answer to this but I'm really interested
in building answers to this based on use
cases
okay so two questions from slido first
one where should I start the
scikit-learn pipeline directly after the
SQL query or is there data managing that
should go before the pipeline
so I'll answer to this one
sorry yeah yes please so this is this is
really a great question so you know if I
if I were to be
purist maybe dogmatic I said you know
directly after this equal query
but so we've done this and then you can
you can you use things that are called
function Transformers and uh Target
Transformers and things like this
it gives you horrible code
so from a pragmatic perspective I'm not
sure exactly so what I hope is to build
those patterns in scrub and we're going
to borrow from existing projects I have
psychic Lego in in mind I need to talk
to Vincent about about this but
basically to build those patterns and
scrubs so that most of the time
the pipeline becomes easy to write when
we start from the SQL query
and and once we have this then we can
have the notion of a data source
which lazy loads the thing and we never
actually materialize the full table
one more question from slido
um is is Panda support in scikit-learn
done or will something improve further
what's I think one of the things that
limit Panda's support in cycle learning
Spenders itself
we're having really a hard time getting
a pen this is an API it's not an
implementation we're having a really
hard time getting an idea of what's the
memory layout how do we avoid copies
which is really really limiting from a
computational perspective
and in a sense so sure some things will
move but uh but we're limited I I don't
know if people have seen the set output
and the recent versions of scikit-learn
which allow you to you know take a
Transformer that takes the panda in and
and give it out uh I'm not very
satisfied by this because there's a lot
of data coping going and copying going
around
I'm more excited about things like
Bowlers supports and this is actually
moving on fairly fast because of the
data frame protocol
thank you so much for the talk
who who likes crop
okay keep your hands up who wants to
contribute to scrub in the future come
on hey yes so you know thank you very
much for coming by thanks for the
sharing this crap position with us Gail
we're now having a break until a quarter
to eight with drinks food upstairs so
yeah
see you soon
[Applause]
15 minutes after after eight yes sir
yeah thank you thank you
should have used scrub